[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
make some mistakes who knows
I think one of the biggest problems we
have in DC is that everyone's egos are
too big I actually prefer to have no
titles at all
[Music]
you're opening yourself up
being me
[Music]
let's go yeah absolutely absolutely
how you doing people I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report it is November 28th
2022 and I hope that you are well fed
and maybe a little bit heavier down
below and uh that you enjoyed some
friends and family and food and all that
good stuff I have to say that out of uh
my 46 years on planet Earth I don't know
that I was ever more thankful than I was
this year obviously with uh with two new
babies in the family and to live here in
the Free State of Florida and things are
good life is good and despite all the
political wackiness which ain't going
away and it's worldwide at this point
and that's what we're going to be
covering today uh I'm just kind of
feeling good about life and uh that'll
be the that'll be the theme for the rest
of 2022 that we can get out of this
nonsense as I was was talking about last
week you know it's uh we can do the
political thing all the time but we also
have to focus on the culture stuff and
figure out how to be sort of happy and
fulfilled and focused and valued amongst
all the craziness so we're back in
studio today it's Phoenix's birthday
well technically it was it was yesterday
but I'm taking the team out tonight and
uh obviously Connor and Daphne you guys
have to order off the children's menu
but Phoenix you can get whatever you
want tonight very exciting and uh so
today we're going to be talking a little
bit about Justin Trudeau he loves drag
queens we're going to be talking about
Anthony fauci he's evil we're gonna be
talking about Klaus Schwab he's super
evil we're going to be talking about the
media they're super duper evil uh and
then we'll bring it around with
something positive at the end I promise
you that real quick before we get to it
let me talk to you guys about Tommy John
you know imagine getting everyone on
your list the perfect gift while it's
still November shop Tommy John's Cyber
Monday sale that's today and give the
gift of comfort to everyone on your list
including yourself with new Tommy John
underwear allow loungewear in pajamas
with over 18 million pairs sold giving
Tommy John has become a holiday
tradition 97 percent of women and men
love getting a gift from Tommy John
that's why Tommy John doesn't have
customers they have Fanatics I love
wearing my Tommy Johns because it makes
me feel refreshed shop Tommy John's
Cyber Monday sale now get 33 percent off
everything plus free shipping at
tommyjohn.com Reuben it's one of the
biggest Tommy John sales of the Year 33
off plus free shipping tommyjohn.com
Reuben see sight for details all right
so I wanted to start the show today
with Justin Trudeau I know you guys like
when we talk about Justin Trudeau he's a
very very evil man he is a puppet of the
world economic Forum he is sort of this
genderless nothing in a suit with nice
socks who sort of sounds like he's
saying the right things but is actually
always doing the the wrong things and
he's he's evil and authoritarian and uh
well he went on to Canada's drag show
that Canada's Got a drag show after you
gotta have a drag show everybody's got
the drag show now he went on Canada's
drag race show and well here's just
watch please help me welcome to the
Canada's drag race work room the prime
minister of Canada Justin Trudeau
laughs
do I have the curtsy do I have to kiss
this ring I heard you had a summit and I
think I'm a little too late yeah
unfortunately we're actually just about
to do makeover episodes
anybody want to take it on
it has been an incredible pleasure to be
part of fighting the good fight on the
right side that is about respecting
people can we move Beyond tolerate and
start embracing and loving and accepting
and learning from it being challenged by
that's how you build a resilient Society
that's what we're trying to do in Canada
and we got a lot of work still to do
you're giving me chills man is he just
so gross so slow Justin Trudeau and then
he comes out shimmying like that and
that way he kind of whisper talks and
it's always about tolerance and
diversity and all of those things but we
know he doesn't like uh actual tolerance
and actual diversity of thought and he's
not very tolerant of people who are
different than him but this is what he
is spending his time on in Canada Canada
has all sorts of problems much like
America there's a worldwide Financial
meltdown they're still dealing with the
repercussions of his Draconian lockdowns
uh there's a whole series of issues that
Canadians are thinking about and dealing
with that have nothing to do with drag
queens but that's what he's doing and
and the contestants were just so
appreciative that the Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau would show up and talk to
them
oh my God I have full body Goosebumps me
too I love him so much because people
like him made it easy for immigrants to
migrate here and have a chance for a
better life so like seeing him being
here is actually like such like it's so
nice so I thank him and people like him
oh you got me girl trying to tear the
girls up girl what do you want me to do
do I have to even comment on this stuff
uh he made he let us in yes it's sort of
like in America where we just let anyone
in now it's oh it's just what is all of
this insanity but there is a reason I'm
showing you this not just to uh point
out that he's wasting time on these drag
shows but actually to compare and
contrast how he appreciates the drag
performer these are wonderfully talented
people by the way let's not besmerge
them how he Compares his feelings
towards the the drag performers versus
the truckers now you remember the
Canadian truckers these were a group of
people thousands and thousands of people
and and actually
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
supporters for them who were fighting
the lockdowns and the mandates that
Trudeau was instigating all throughout
Canada and then of course they started
looking into their bank accounts and a
whole bunch of really awful stuff uh
well Trudeau was asked uh just in the
last couple days why he didn't negotiate
with the truckers and his answer is
quite telling
they wanted to engage and they wanted
you to speak to them and they wanted to
hear directly from their federal
government and that did not happen so do
you have an answer to that
um
I think first of all
we heard them we knew exactly what they
were asking for they were very very
clear that they wanted an end to
mandates
but it was
clear that it wasn't
that they just wanted to be heard
they wanted to be obeyed
isn't he something else confession
through projection right he wanted to be
obeyed the truckers wanted their country
to open up the truckers wanted to go to
work and live as free citizens in a
western democracy which is what they
thought Canada was and by the way Canada
was before Justin Trudeau but no somehow
they wanted to be obeyed no you were the
one that was firing all of these people
you were the one that was ruining the
economy and ruining all their lives but
again he does it he's so slick I mean he
he and Gavin Newsom it's this thing
there they're slick and they sort of if
you're not really paying attention at
all kind of sounds right and then what
do you have to do you peel off that very
thin veneer of Tolerance and
progressivism and you find the worst
sort of angry authoritarian uh here's a
little more from Trudeau and I don't
think he really understands what being a
leader in a western country is all about
when it comes to respecting people who
might protest you we have a robust
functioning democracy and uh protests
public protests are an important part of
making sure we're getting messages out
there and Canadians are getting messages
out there and highlighting how they feel
about various issues uh but using
protests to
demand changes to public policy is
something that that I think is is is
worrisome did you catch that do you see
what this guy's doing uh dude that's
what you use protest for you use protest
hopefully peaceful protest right I know
the left's not a big fan of peaceful
protests but you use peaceful protest so
that you can actually make change so
that you can get policies to change so
you can get politicians to listen to you
and by the way that's exactly what the
freaking truckers did they were peaceful
they were respectful there were videos
we played of them cleaning up after they
would protest right that's in stark
contrast to what happens when antifa and
BLM were protesting down here in America
or up there in Canada
um so he's this idea that oh you protest
but it's not so you can change things
that's exactly the point that's exactly
what it is but he masks his tyranny with
the label of democracy and tolerance and
decency which is exactly what we're
seeing down here that's why there's
something so interesting happening in
the world that I guess is a function of
the internet now that the the good ideas
and the bad ideas they're all going
worldwide at the same exact time so the
problems that we're having in America
are virtually the same problems that
they're having in Canada which are the
same problems they're having in
Australia and Italy and all over the
world uh on a positive note though
related to all of this Anthony fauci is
leaving he is almost done his reign of
terror is coming to a close but of
course as he ends his reign of terror he
has to backtrack and lie about almost
everything that his reign of terror
actually did to all of us and he has to
do it all over television we've got to
make sure this guy gets a serious hand
job before he leaves and uh nobody wants
to picture that that I'm sorry about
that that's a little early for that
um here's fauci on whether we're gonna
close schools again this is his goodbye
Tour all over the media last couple days
and remember he was never four closing
schools but he was for closing schools
he wasn't for Mass he was from us he's
taken every position on everything
somehow we're back to talking about
whether schools are going to stay open
or not so coming out of the holidays
should parents expect schools to shut
down I don't know uh Margaret I'm not
sure when you talk about shutting down
schools there's always the collapse
that's also radioactively it is exactly
there's always the collateral issues the
fact that he can even laugh that even
has the balls to show up on these shows
that he's pretends that he had nothing
to do remember we played in the video a
couple weeks ago him pretending that he
had nothing to do with lockdowns and
then you can find videos of him calling
for lockdowns I had nothing to do with
school closures and you can find it uh
what really is going on here is guys yes
the answer is yes there will be more
lockdowns of course there will be
lockdowns whether it's covid lockdowns
or climate lockdowns or something all
over the world not just in our elections
of a couple weeks ago but all over the
world the people who were the most
Draconian who locked down the most
people who ruined the most Lives who
forced people to get the most Jabs all
those things they all got reelected it
just happened in Australia too the idea
that Gretchen Whitmer was reelected
people said thank you sir may I have
another the idea that any of these
people in any of these places Kathy
hochel they want more in New York so
there will be more lockdowns there will
be more school closures but it will be
in blue States that's how it's going to
be it's just it ain't going to happen in
Florida I promise you not uh but the
other piece of fauci leaving is that he
wants to make sure that he's still
worshiped by everybody and he's not
happy that the Republicans don't like
him they've clearly politicized that you
know they say that I've be I'm not
political at all period I've never been
and anybody who knows anything about me
knows that that's the case but it is
very clear when people are running their
campaigns with an anti-faulty element to
it I mean that's ridiculous he's not
political at all he is the highest paid
person in the government and I think the
government has a little something to do
with politics but he's not political at
all and really it was just Republicans
using his name and his words to
fundraise and get votes and scare people
the only reason Republicans were doing
any of that is because you were the one
that was pushing the lockdowns endless
school closures and the masks and all
that but
we found this great compilation video of
fauci taking every which position you
could possibly take on masks and I think
it gets to the heart of why he's leaving
in such a blaze of nothingness because
people actually can see through it
people should not be walking around with
masks let me just State for the record
that masks are not theater wearing a
mask might make people feel a little bit
better and masks are protective and but
it's not providing the Perfect
protection that people think that it is
there has not been any indication that
putting a mask on and wearing a mask for
a considerable period of time has any
deleterious effects there are unintended
consequences people keep fiddling with
the mask and they keep touching their
face and can you get some Schmutz sort
of staying inside there of course you do
not need to wear a mask indoors if in
fact you've been vaccinated good that
you're vaccinated but in a situation
where you have people indoors
particularly crowded you should wear a
mask so even if you are vaccinated you
should wear a man
man it really is incredible you know
like it's like you could kind of laugh
at that and you can share that video and
you can show people like man he took
every position on everything but then if
you really think it through it's like
why are people so screwed up about
almost everything these days because the
the thought leaders the people that were
supposed to be the adults in the room
the mature honest brokers in the midst
of a pandemic or whatever is going on in
the world politically or anything else
they all failed us fauci should be
embarrassed NBC news or ABC news or CNN
whoever puts him on I mean now he's
really in the in the goodbye phase so I
don't know hopefully we just won't see
much of them anymore but like why didn't
someone at a news organization play that
for fauci and then say Hey so uh you
know you've been doing this for about
three years now and uh
what about that what about the fact that
you said literally everything you could
possibly say in direct conflict with
yourself would that be worth doing if
you were say a journalist you know I
know there's none out there uh here's
video from the White House as fauci was
saying goodbye to everybody and I do
want to warn you I believe that this is
slightly edited I'm unclear on that but
I think it might have been slightly
slightly edited so my message and my
final message may be the final message I
give you from this Podium is that please
for your own safety for that of your
family get your updated covid-19 shot as
soon as you're eligible to protect
yourself your family and your community
unclear if that was edited to me but uh
yes he's still pushing vaccines no
fouchy I did not get vaxed and I am not
getting vaxed and I certainly would not
get vaxed under your advice right if uh
if the time comes and I talked to my
doctor and whatever blah blah blah okay
but the idea that just people would just
take a blanket statement from fauci at
this point yes get vaxed and get boosted
he's vaxed and boosted 18 times and he's
had covered several times and the head
of Pfizer who had 87 booster shots he's
been uh he got covered like two weeks
ago it just is it just is there are more
people now dying of covid that are
vaxxed than are not vax Washington Post
just reported on that and uh well fauci
he's still saying that it's the unvaxed
who are the real danger vaccinated and
unboosted versus vaccinated plus boosted
that doesn't mean you shouldn't get
boosted but the real Danger isn't the
people who have not been vaccinated so
that's where we expect if we're going to
see a problem this winter
huh you know what Connor I'm going to
pull an audible here we're going to
throw right to the Biden thing because
you remember Joe Biden last year it was
right around now last year it was I
think right between Thanksgiving and
Christmas last year when Joe Biden said
the winter of death was coming I mean
that's what fauci's doing again it's a
year later and they're still if you are
unvaxed you're going to kill grandma and
you're most likely going to kill
yourself uh well here's the winter of
death from a year ago for unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death for unveax yeah we
didn't get that winter of severe illness
or death uh actually we I can just give
you a personal anecdote we arrived in
Miami in Florida we moved here it was
about a year ago right when that was
dropped and everyone was getting covered
here including us and everyone wanted to
get covet actually pretty much everybody
was like oh omicron's around it's not
that dangerous let's get sick you'll
have some natural immunity that'll be it
I was at party after party because it's
holiday holidays right so I'm at
Christmas parties and everyone was like
you oh you you're not feeling that great
okay let's hang Let's Dance
stupid people but they're still doing it
again they're still doing it again
here's Dr Ashish
and he wants to scare the hell out of
you too an important part of the
conversation we have in the days and
weeks ahead
because here's what we know
if folks get their updated vaccines
and they get treated they have a
breakthrough infection
we can prevent essentially every coveted
death in America
it's a complete lie it's just a lie come
fact check me delete my channel YouTube
it's just a lie there are no studies
about this there are no long-term
studies that say if you get vaxxed and
boosted that you're getting the Lesser
covet it just isn't reality it is not
reality but why am I telling you all
this no one wants to hear videos of
fauci I understand you're sitting at
home going Dave I can't take it anymore
nobody wants these videos about you so
I've got one more for you because now
I'm going to link it to everything else
we're doing on the show today uh fauci
was asked this weekend about what's
going on in China because you know China
has this zero covid policy which has led
to if you think Michigan and New York
and California had crazy lockdowns I
mean they are locking people in
buildings they are closing cities it is
absolutely insane fauci was asked about
China's approach what is going on in
China and why do they seem to be in a
worse place than anyone else in the
world well their approach has been very
very severe and rather Draconian in the
kinds of shutdowns without a seeming
purpose
Draconian without a purpose now could it
be without a purpose would a Communist
Regime that is bent on maintaining power
and bent on keeping people all doing the
exact same thing and not questioning
Authority and all that could there be a
purpose behind them locking their people
down could there be a purpose there he
can't figure it out it doesn't make any
sense why would that Communist Regime do
that he has no freaking idea well here's
Klaus Schwab I know you guys like Klaus
Schwab you know Klaus Schwab from the
world economic Forum who's right out of
like Hollywood 101 the evil guy uh he
seemingly is running half of the world
right now and uh even though fauci can't
figure out why China would want these
lockdowns
um I think Schwab is kind of onto
something and understands maybe why
China would do this and perhaps we could
extrapolate that and send it across the
globe on the G20 you were there meeting
some of the leaders as well Professor
schwaba what do you make up the result
finally they put something as a
statement and it seems quite positive
with all the voices included I think
it's positive it's already positive so
the fact that everybody agreed about the
statement which we haven't had the last
years now surveys has been formed but we
have to go one step further we have to
have a strategic mood we have to
construct the World of Tomorrow it's a
systemic transformation of the world so
we have to Define how the world should
look like which we want to come out of
this transformation period
I uh respect China's
achievements which are tremendous over
the last over 40 years I think it's
um a role model for many countries that
I think also
we should leave it to each country
to make its own decision what system it
wants to adapt and I think we should be
very careful in imposing systems but the
Chinese model is certainly a very
attractive model for quite an American
okay so he's speaking out of both sides
of his mouth there you see what he did
at the end right he's running something
called the world economic Forum he
brings in all these world leaders and
then through ESG scores and everything
else they figure out ways to manipulate
their people right and they figure out
ways to silence dissent and everything
that happened in Canada and Australia et
cetera et cetera so on one hand he's
like but I believe in Sovereign Nations
and everyone can do what they want but
China done a really hell of a job here
so even though fauci from the clip
before fauci has no idea why they would
do these Draconian lockdowns yeah he
doesn't know why China would do it why
would you have that zero policy related
to kovid but Klaus Schwab is telling you
why because you want a as he said we
want to construct the World of Tomorrow
we want a systemic transformation of the
world these people are doing it in plain
sight so while Klaus Schwab is very he
has very nice things to say about the
last 40 Years of China sure they've
completely silenced dissent you know
individual rights aren't respected as I
said they're literally locking people in
apartment buildings and people are
starving to death in their Apartments
we're going to show you some crazy
videos in just a moment he really is
into that sort of thing here's a little
bit more from the daily wire on what's
going on in China Chinese citizens are
protesting the Communist nation's strict
coven policies with at least one
demonstration turning violent protests
intensified over the weekend in major
cities across China including Beijing
Shanghai and Wuhan according to Media
reports a demonstration in Shanghai
eventually devolved into chaos with
police clashing with protesters and
deploying pepper spray the protests
emerged as a response to the zero covid
policies imposed by the Chinese
communist government since the beginning
of the pandemic now there are
there are hundreds and hundreds probably
probably far more than that of videos
going across mostly across Twitter right
now because Twitter is less censored
than some of the other social media
platforms because of that scary Elon
Musk guy of Chaos in China and people
literally locked in buildings people
begging from you from 40 floors up
begging for food little children being
separated from their parents horrible
stuff are you seeing that on CNN is
Washington Post doing much about that is
MSNBC covering that isn't that bizarre
sort of like the election stuff that's
happening down in Brazil why did
mainstream media cover that it's almost
as if they don't like when you can see
that you the people have some power and
you can organize against the powers that
be very bizarre I'm gonna have to think
about that a little bit more here's some
video of these coveted protests this is
Wuhan China and it's actually earlier
this morning I think
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
these people have had enough there's no
such thing as a zero covid policy that
no one will get sick the virus exists in
nature it exists in the world the
communist government is using it as an
excuse to crack down on its people to
show them that they can't fight the
government to make them more dependent
on the government does it sound a little
familiar to what's going on here in
America it's just to a different degree
and then when you think about the people
that literally voted for it again a
couple weeks ago that said hey you
locked me down you didn't let me go to
work you kicked my kid out of school
sure my kids having speech delays blah
blah blah let's give you some more power
over me and what this all leads to also
is that obviously in China they don't
have free market capitalism right it is
a communist system in in China what we
have here for the most part is still
some level of free market capitalism
it's a little screwy and it's hanging on
by a thread but we still have it so what
happened speaking of capitalism in the
last couple weeks well Elon Musk bought
Twitter now why did he buy Twitter why
would a guy who's sending Rockets to
Mars who's doing starlink and neural
Link and he's building underground
tunnels in Los Angeles why would a guy
who's doing all of this stuff why would
he buy Twitter a product that is losing
money he's now losing money by having it
and buy it at premium well I sense that
he felt that free speech is worth
fighting for and he put his butt online
and I think actually he's also planning
to make some money on it right that's a
nice benefit of it I don't think he's
just doing this to lose money and
everything else but he's all he's done
so far on Twitter
and as I always say guys if you're not
on Twitter stay off Twitter and God
bless you but what he has done and I can
tell you this as someone that's on
Twitter
since he's been on Twitter he's just
allowing people to say more things less
accounts are being banned he's brought
some accounts back before him people
said mean things on Twitter after him
people say mean things on Twitter but
the machine is freaking out right
mainstream media which which wants the
control corporate press which wants the
control big Tech before Elon which wants
the control they don't like someone
coming in and letting people just say
what they want they can't have that so
here's uh former CIA analyst Robert bear
explaining how Elon Musk is and is
bringing more evil to the world that's
raising some serious National Security
concerns new Twitter owner Elon Musk
says that he is going to begin restoring
previously banned accounts next week
that includes users banned for threats
and harassment musk announced the
decision after conducting an online poll
he tweeted quote the people have spoken
amnesty begins next week and then in
Latin the voice of the people is the
voice of God joining us now is CNN
intelligence and security analyst Bob
bear Bob thanks for joining us we hope
you're enjoying the Thanksgiving holiday
I'm curious to get your reaction to
these accounts being reinstated
well Boris I can tell you one thing
Putin is going to be all over Twitter if
there's no regulations on this fake
accounts spoofed accounts the rest of it
this is a great opportunity for him and
so when he's talking about the popular
voice mosque is really talking about
Russian intelligence
man it's incredible they do it over and
over again and huge swaths of people
will fall for it what's going to happen
to Twitter now that Elon Musk is saying
it can be a little more pro-free speech
well of course guys it's a Russian
operation and who's going to benefit the
most it'll be Vladimir Putin like can
you like they the script isn't even that
good would you lizard people who are
writing the scripts please give us
better scripts because this stuff is all
too obvious
um it is complete nonsense there were
bots on Twitter before Elon there will
be bots on Twitter after Elon people
will say mean things before people say
mean things to me all day long on
Twitter and you know what you can do you
can either not look at them you cannot
open your phone and endlessly Doom
scroll or you can block them and you can
mute them that's what you can do but if
you were actually being threatened as
they say that well there are it's going
to be more threats and harassment if
you're actually being threatened
physically threatened or doxxed or
something like that you got a problem
with the law
the person doing it has a problem with
the law and then the law will step in
right the police will step in the
intelligence services will step in okay
harassment yeah people say mean things
to people it's crazy there are people
online I know this is going to blow you
guys away there are people online who
don't like me
there's a couple of them out there and
they tweeted me and you know what you
just ignore it or you block them or
whatever CNN's freaking out though
because of course not only will the
Russians take advantage of this but of
course somehow Twitter will be more
racist right
this is good here's a tweet from CNN
black Twitter is mourning the possible
end of the influential Community they
found on Twitter more than a decade ago
but users are split between finding a
new app or staying put now this is
actually hilarious first off there's no
such thing as black Twitter there's
Twitter and sometimes black people use
Twitter and white people use Twitter and
Chinese people use Twitter and gay
people use Twitter it's all the same
Twitter okay it's all the same Twitter
uh but now because Elon Musk is just
coming in and saying hey we're going to
respect Free Speech a little bit more
apparently CNN thinks that black people
are going to freak out and better start
their own thing now it's kind of funny
because for all the years that
conservatives were saying boy we're
being Shadow banned and our accounts are
being nuked and Jordan Peterson is
suspended and James Lindsay's not on
Twitter anymore and all of this stuff uh
they kept saying and the media
constantly was doing this well go build
your own thing and then parlor was built
and then parlor was nuked by Amazon I
started locals this is why rumble's in
business so if these people are not
happy I guess they could go build things
now the problem is it's hard to build
things when instead of caring about
hiring the best say engineers and
product designers and things of that
nature you're instead hiring people
based on their genitals and their skin
color so they're not going to build
anything but people I guess black
Twitter is freaking out right now uh and
uh interestingly it's all connected when
you connect the uh when you see the dots
it's like the big Tech thing it's so
connected to the corporate thing here's
a tweet from outkick ratings at CNN are
so bad they are already ditching their
Centrist pivot so what's interesting
about this of course is that
you know they get rid of uh who's the
guy uh Zucker they get rid of Jeff
Zucker over at CNN because he made them
two parties in the left and it was too
obvious for everybody they bring in this
new guy he says let's go Center nobody's
watching anymore and now they're getting
rid of that so although you can see what
I'm putting together here everything
whether it's about coveted lockdowns
whether it's about speech it's all
it's all that filter it's all stuck in
this filter that we have that is the
lying corporate press and the people
that want big Tech to be censored more
so how can I bring this to something
that will make you feel good because I
showed you China could be kind of
depressing that might be coming to
California you never know well you know
what we can do there are some things we
can do and they're baked into the system
right here in the United States because
we have a beautiful system founded on
the right ideals we really do we've got
things like the Constitution and the
Bill of Rights and the Declaration of
Independence and The Federalist Papers
all of these documents written by people
who were far better than any of the
people in our public sphere today with
with maybe a couple exceptions and they
gave us this they gave us this blessing
of freedom and we can restore it we
really can restore it but we're gonna
have to put in the work uh Jordan
Peterson was on Russell Brand's podcast
a couple days ago and they were talking
about this idea between in individual
rights authoritarian governments and why
governments when fauci earlier he
doesn't know why China would do
something like this but there is a
reason and Jordan explains it quite well
generally speaking Center left liberal
democracies are using this stuff
nefariously I don't think they care
about the feelings of trans people I
don't think they care I I don't think so
either I care I care and I care about
white Working Class People black Working
Class People brown people from across
the all-class Spectra and what I feel
like is that in order to not engulf
ourselves in a sort of a semantic pyre
we all refocus our attention on the real
giants the oligarchs the tyrants whether
they're buratic or personal that are
using the are narcissistically hoovering
up the power while we're [ __ ] around
with like well this is also this is also
partly the dangerous of the danger of
elevating compassion to the ultimate
virtue because you will you also enable
the narcissists of compassion to Garner
power to themselves by claiming a
compassion they don't have if you
destabilize the identity of local
individuals so they're confused and
aimless it's a hell of a lot easier to
Hoover up all the power
you need slaves to be a tyrant and maybe
I'm more concerned about the individuals
on the slave level and you're more
concerned with delineating the nature of
the Tyranny and that's perfectly fine
but I think they're the same problem
do you see what we did here on the
Reuben report program today do you see
how we tied this thing together we
started about a half hour ago talking
about Justin Trudeau and the trans
people or the the drag people I assume
well probably one or two of them are
trans as well but he comes in there just
introduce who locked these people down
who ruined Canada's economy who shredded
their founding documents but he comes in
and he sounds nice and he's shimmying
and all those things and then they look
at him despite everything he did to them
and he's oh my God he loves us he loves
us he just loves us so much and then
they become atomized they're not even
real individuals anymore they're just oh
you're the trans people you're the drag
people you behave like this this is how
you should behave and you will not be an
individual so I want to Now read you
Jordan's quote right there that he just
said at the end and you'll see how this
thing all got linked together to why
fauci doesn't know why they would have
lockdowns
and all the rest of it this is Jordan's
quote if you destabilize the identity of
local individuals so they're confused
and aimless it's a hell of a lot easier
to Hoover up all the power you need
slaves to be a tyrant so do you see why
they would want you constantly focused
on gender and sexuality and race and all
of these things that actually don't
matter that much but they make you feel
like those are the most important things
about you and once you think that your
gender and your sexuality are the most
important things in your skin color the
real piece of you the piece of you that
is the thinking you that is within this
skin
with the gender and the genitals and all
the stuff that part will be completely
gone and then they will be able to lock
you down like they're doing in China and
with a zero coveted policy and then our
nonsensical bureaucrats
like Anthony fauci who deserved no power
over anybody and can't figure out why
China would do a thing like that well if
you if you had a belief in yourself if
you had a belief in autonomy and
individuality you would not be giving
power over to them so whether it is
Trudeau or fauci or Klaus Schwab or
China or the media
I believe you know how to live your life
they believe that they know how to live
your life and you got to pick a side
that's really where we're at right now
guys it is me Monday over at the Reuben
report locals community and uh here's
the one that I put up so this is
actually technically if we were to
technically Define what a meme is I
don't know that this is actually a meme
because there's no words on it but this
is a picture so Joe Biden was in
Nantucket over the weekend celebrating
Thanksgiving and he approached this
window so these two girls took the
selfie and I feel like that's just like
the perfect summation like was he
sniffing do you think he was sniffing
through the window does the scent of the
hair get through the window it's just
kind of just kind of perfect if you want
to jump in and share some other memes uh
you can go to reubenreport.locals.com
let's get a couple comments from the
community EK says fauci I'm not
political I want to kill everyone
equally anyone that says that you know
I'm not political line it reminds me of
that that clip we've shown it of Don
Lemon a couple times I'm not political
what do you mean you talk about politics
all day long do you have no thoughts
related to any of this stuff fauci I'm
not political uh when you are writing
policy
that is locking people in their homes or
shutting down the economy or the Litany
of other things that you've done you are
by default political but he doesn't want
to be thought of as political because
what is he he is the science don't
forget that right if you question fauci
you're actually questioning science
Hallie says Schwab likes the China model
that would be the model where 40 million
Chinese starve to death during the Great
Leap Forward right exactly like why is
it that you're not seeing the videos of
China on mainstream media as I showed
you or what's going on in Brazil as
millions of people are upset with the
election results down there they don't
want you to realize that you have power
but you do have power and that's why
they're freaking out about Elon Musk I
don't want people to be endlessly trolls
and racists online trust me it's not
there was a time in my life years ago
when I first started getting hate that
it would be upsetting I'd open Twitter
it's not fun it's not fun but you have
some power to control it over yourself
you have some power to exercise let's
say a degree of maturity when you're
online it's not that we want everyone to
be mean online but I guess being mean is
part of the human condition and unless
you're going to kill an awful lot of
people you're not going to kill meanness
uh Anka says these last three years
showed us that people would rather be
part of the group than be right yeah
man what did I say many times over the
last couple years it's like if you
stayed roughly sane through all of this
if you stayed roughly sane then you're
pretty good at my book and actually
speaking of that one thing we didn't get
to cover today and I'm sure I'll talk
about at least on the margins over the
next little while is that Sam Harris who
obviously was hugely influential in my
political Awakening and everything else
he actually deleted his Twitter account
over the weekend he was he got into it
with Elon a little bit and he doesn't
want Trump back on he doesn't want Alex
Jones back on and a lot of people were
turning on him he was he was thought of
as this sort of you know he's this new
atheist but thought of as like a free
speech Warrior and suddenly he was this
is the same guy who thanked Jack when
Jack Dorsey banned Trump on Twitter uh
Sam went out of his way to thank him
which I thought was a little bit odd
it's like you could probably just be
quiet about it instead of telling people
you're happy that they can just you know
silence the president's Free Speech Etc
but he deleted his uh Twitter account
and I think it's a it's an oddly seminal
moment it's a different topic altogether
but you know that that's sort of the The
Atheist movement has just collapsed it
has completely collapsed that's a we'll
do a different show on that all together
uh anyway it's good to be back guys I
hope uh as I said at the beginning I
hope you are feeling well fed and ready
to roll into the holiday season uh if
you have not subscribed yet join us at
rumble.com reubenreport if you want to
play along during the show with live
chat and get plenty of pictures of the
kids and all sorts of stuff
reubenreport.locals.com and we leave you
with the elderly man pretending to be
president
thank you
imagine
this has to be boring boring boring for
these kids to stand up here
you're allowed to do anything you want
including go steal a pumpkin if you want
anything you want to do